hello and welcome to this video yeah in
the last video there were some remarks
that somehow the recording area was
slightly off and I agree somehow it was
not quite as intended so I made some
adjustments but I'm only now during the
game can check if everything works it
looks fine to me I would have to check
on how it looks like in them analysis
view it's a bit odd that all of a sudden
there were changes that most likely due
to my vacation where I used them the
notebook screen still a little bit odd
ok let's see what happened him white has
played yeah a color
Zuko to what I think it is called Queen
e1 is an odd move I think he wants to go
Knight e5 hmm I have I'm drawn to this
idea and I really can't resist playing
it let's do it
I believe if he if he captures I'm fine
and indeed it did not capture ok so let
me take this this was white some
strongest piece of the bishop on d3 so
how do I go about this
maybe Queen to b6 simply preventing c4 I
am NOT preventing c4 no it's okay I was
thinking c4 d takes B takes Queen B to
adjust Ruby one my queen is trapped I
was a bit silly but ok one
point was that I wanted to allow the ruk
to come to d8 one regrouping that I want
to play is g6 Bishop f8 Bishop to g7 the
bishop should point towards the center
it's not really all that great on e7
Roxy one is slightly mysterious to see
him prepare oh that's not that that I
didn't expect to happen at all okay let
that changes the whole outline of the
position what is he up to night b3 maybe
tomorrow
c5 I don't see the upside of before
because he puts yet another pawn on a
dark square so his Bishop becomes worse
the movie a6 intends to play Queen to be
five because I would be happy with the
trade and the queen is not bad there
let's see what is what is up - if we
place the Queen away and there is maybe
there is Queen to e3 sorry okay so we
just trade yeah I think this is a good
transformation for me because the b5
point is not a week because it is no way
for him to attack it it can only play
like night b12 c3 but that is extremely
artificial yeah this one but this night
is heading exactly where my idea is 98
d6 d4 and that is a really really really
strong night he cannot go to c5 because
I have b6 that's the difference here the
move B form was
basically weakening a c4 for no
particular reason
and after f4 here's weakened Evo as well
that's an interesting that's interesting
now how do i how do I go about this I
can also use the e4 square which is
actually even more maybe more attractive
even huh
night-night BH d7 g7 f64 with an idea
very slow but got time sorry my voice is
a little bit of recording this in the
morning
I don't have a clear plan yet how to
actually make this count yeah this bad
this bad bishop but I don't have to I
just have to improve the position slowly
and things then will work out you get a
clearer picture step by step improving
piece after piece and only then you
think about a grand plan you don't need
a grand plan now here for example with
the trade now I can actually think about
kicking the night away or trade it off
there are this is also possible a team
okay first of all I can now regroup this
to see for right like in 92 but it
doesn't doesn't lead to that much okay
let's do what looks fine anyhow
f6 push this away put the bishop on to
d6 wait I should think about no I don't
want him to trade I take only form okay
maybe I should have played it
differently right it's not exactly what
I wanted that he trades this but it's
it's still better for black I doesn't
trade it okay
so then I'm going for g5 probably I can
do it already could have prepared
prepared it even more but I'm not sure
that I needed to I mean I'm playing
basically a piece up now with the the
bishops still stand on B to g4 maybe is
a mafia
but I have this one and now probably
doubling under doubling here on the edge
farm yeah is he only has a check there
one chick oh yeah okay this analysis
network saw dia with this Queen estate
it's okay right okay so let's have a
look there it looked like I had good
control why it was playing this form of
a collar
Zuka thought system I don't really
believe this is very dangerous in this
particular move order I think the three
setups the college setups are a bit more
interesting once black has committed to
e6 because him I believe black has very
easy play with c5 can also think of g6
but c5 is I think a good a good move the
best now for white is probably just to
play c4 and then there are multiple
transposition with transposition sub
black can take here for Queens gambit
accepted or here which is what I would
do to go into a harmless version of the
panel CARICOM okay b3 however was played
and no I think I'm just happy with the
simple development scheme that I played
here black has naturalized already so
yeah one thing that I was wondering
after playing if I had tonight before at
some point but there always is a check
you know was check me and and I have to
back ok and now he played a three
because night before was a threat if he
would play something yeah like this I
have night before and if he wants to
preserve the Bishop Bishop f5 is
extremely problematic yeah something
like this is quite embarrassing so a
three is necessary and then plate Lucas
the aid Queen e1 and Bishop f5 yeah this
is an interesting choice I think it
isn't it is playable for sure because
this looks comfortable you know the
double pony is helpful to support a
knight coming to you for work and a rook
to e8 and I'm already thinking about
making this bishop look silly and this
is actually yam it's in the works and
this bishop has very little space he
went Queen e2 and I captured Queen b6
yeah I was thinking at first I would
prevent c4 because I don't yeah he can
still play this because this would
blunder the Queen get a bit of material
don't seem so yeah okay I got a piece
and the route but it makes no sense
after c4 I didn't I wouldn't have taken
of course but rather played something
like Queen a6 a it's one of the engines
most it wasn't planned but I would have
done that okay look see one route g8 is
very normal on before and no I keep
playing engine moves that's not bad
I like this a six idea six couldn't be
five yeah it's not the only move before
as I think very strategically dubious
move you can also start with the 98 when
where you want to connect with with the
square but a six I think it makes sense
it makes sense couldn't be fine I think
now you should probably move the Queen
and not straight after the creature I
did gets so one-sided here I will go a
five I think yeah I mean you're just
sitting on a bad piece there
and now again it's very one-sided
I just prevent him from jumping to c5
and here oh I could have gone nighty
form there's of course a bit better the
same idea I always had 98 he ate d6 in
mind and I did not realized after he
went to b3 so and now I'm not sure that
b8 is probably better slow yes it's
really you just keep an advantage
because of the long-term nature of the
whole thing right you form yeah that's
very comfortable f6 push this back in g7
night f2 f5 yeah it's just it's just
clearly better what can you do and now
you play aged 65 it looks like a very
straightforward strategic game but
white-haired there's a clean the whole I
could have possible at you yeah it's not
much to say it's just just a very
straightforward strategic win I think it
comes to this situation here where I'm
definitely comfortable but it's not I
mean you don't have a really clear way
forward I mean I would have played g6
and bring the Bishop to g7 but there's
not fantastic or anything
I mean blackest probably slightly better
but it gets really ugly after before
which is what's another move that has a
clear upside now you allow Knight b3 and
potentially go to see fire but I said
that's so easily prevented with b6 and
even if it would arrive on c5 it
wouldn't be very threatening can always
kick it out or simply ignore the piece
so this is a move that has little upside
but many downsides making the bishop
worse and wreaking all the squares okay
thanks for watching